- Devin Williams is our National League
Rookie of the Year, and Harry Doyle will—
- Let's gooo!
- It's an honor and a privilege to
present the 2020 Jackie Robinson
Rookie of the Year award in the
American League to Kyle Lewis.
Welcome to the club, Kyle.
- Yes, sir. Thank you, guys.
Thank you, guys. Thank you, guys.
You know, to have a Black hitter
and a Black pitcher in the same
year is something that—it’s something
out of a storybook or something.
- All right, gentlemen. Honored to be
here with you guys, four Rookies of the Year.
So, I feel like I'm left out the
party, to be honest. I'm looking
like, you know—I mean, Ryan, I was
there with you when you won it. Doc,
I was a youngster watching
you, trying to be like you.
You know, with the big hook and just filthy.
Devin, Kyle, the newest generation.
The first to do it since ‘84, having two Black
young men win Rookie of the Year.
I mean, it's an honor.
I hope you guys understand what that
means to us as a community, obviously as
players and role models, but, in light of
everything, what that has really meant.
I personally feel that winning this
year had a slightly different meaning
than it would
have had in the past
in light of everything. With that
being said, it's almost like—and it’s
sad that once, you know, one Rookie
of the Year is announced and he's
Black, he's African-American, and you
know who's up in the other league,
you start to think it's impossible.
Like, why? Like, we've been almost
trained and programmed to be, “Well,
we have enough. You know, we got one.
Don't ask for more than that.
You got your one.
So, be happy with that.”
What does it mean to you to win given the
environment that we're living in today?
And I'll start with you, Devin.
- I think for both of us from both sides of the game—
you know, me on the mound and him as
a position player—to be an example
for these kids out here, you know,
and kinda be a light and
show them that this is a game
that's here for them as well,
I think that was a really special moment.
- OK. Lew?
- It means a lot for me, you
know, being with my family and
seeing him win. You know, as I was
getting set up, you know, it
brought tears to my eyes to see,
especially a Black pitcher. You know,
that's, you know, a rare thing, man.
So, that's super special
and super proud of
you know, the way that we're able to
represent the game. And the messages you
receive after that, you know, it really
means a lot. Put it into perspective,
you know, even in ways I probably
wasn't able to understand, you know,
until afterwards. And just being able
to move around in the community now, see
the kids, see the reception that they
have, you know, when you show up and
the inspiration that they give.
Yeahhh, we out here!
You know, it continues to put it
into perspective every day.
So, I just continue to
try to carry that on.
And blessed to be the next in line. Excited to
see who comes next, cuz, you know, to
have a Black hitter and a Black pitcher
in the same year, it's just something
that—it’s something out of a storybook or something.
- Now, Doc, what was your experience like?
I mean, you were—it hadn’t
been done since the ‘84 season.
Was it the same way?
Like, feeling that, obviously any time
we win something that, as Black
people—and it's done on both
sides of the aisle—there's a sense of Black
pride. We talk about Black pride.
But it's hard to explain
what it feels like.
It's hard to put in words.
It's something you feel, and
you will never forget that feeling.
So, Doc, in ‘84, when you were
going through it and seeing
it happen and living it,
what was that experience like?
And, you know, seeing it happen
again so many years later, how do
you feel about these two young men
that went out and won the awards?
- First, congratulations to both of you guys,
Devin and Kyle.
I think, for me, like you said,
it had been ‘84 with myself
and Alvin Davis winning it.
It’s great to see, man. Cuz
I'm a big fan of the game.
This just puts extra, extra pride on
top of it when you see two guys,
especially a Black pitcher, win that award, man.
And then Kyle winning it as well
is just a great thing, man, to see. Proud of these guys.
- Now, Big Piece.
- Yes, sir.
You have a history, or at least
your family has a history, your
parents, and, you know, maybe not a
lot of people even know about this.
I'm gonna leave it at that.
- You know, I come from a family—
my parents were both born and raised in
Birmingham, Alabama. Came up in the civil
rights movement. Pops was out there,
you know, getting chased down by the dogs
and hit with the hoses and everything.
So, understanding that dynamic of,
you know, where we come from as a
people, that strength, that resolve,
that resilience is what's helped
shape me into who I am today.
I try to pay it back
forward as much as I can.
You know, being able to talk to
young players, young Black
players and letting them know, because
in seeing what's going on in
today's society and understanding
where it was, where the game was
when Doc came up to where, Jimmy,
where you and I came up, to where the
game is with Devin and Kyle has—
I mean, it's just been
strides and strides and strides in
the right direction currently today,
because all this stuff that's going on
today is stuff that's been going on.
Now, the light has been shined on it
even more than what it ever did because
everybody's media. These cell phones tell,
you know, the videos and the
cell phones and all that kind of stuff.
You can't hide from the video.
If the video shows you doing this,
they got you on video.
So,
I think in today's society, to your
question also, Jimmy, about
is the game different in baseball?
I think it's different because
the light has been shined on it.
And you still have people today being
like, “Just shut up and play.”
Well, let me tell you something.
I'm a man first and foremost.
Yes,
I put this uniform on.
And yeah, this is how I pay my bills,
but I'm a man first and foremost, and
I damn sure wanna be treated like one.
And that's what it's all about, man,
is regardless of what you do—
I don't care if you change oil,
I don't care if you work on roofs,
man. You are a man, and you are a woman,
and you should be treated as a human
being with all kind of respects,
regardless of what that paycheck looks like.
- Devin and Kyle,
how did what happened this summer,
Black Lives Matter,
how did that connect everyone?
Obviously we know about the Players
Alliance, how that all came about.
Now, we're all in on a group, whether
we’re out of the game, coming to
the end or just starting. But how did
you guys as Black players find
one another, connect, communicate
and say, you know, “What can we do?”
- Yeah.
I think it just, it brought the Black
community and baseball closer together.
You know what I mean?
Like, everyone was just kind
of there for each other.
You know, if you need something,
you can always reach out.
Like, I mean, I can't even tell you how
many texts I got like that from older
players, like, in the game or retired
guys. Like, and I mean, it was just
a good support system for me to have,
especially being a rookie, you know?
Being the only Black guy in my
clubhouse since LoCain, he opted out.
So, I was the only Black guy.
It was good to have people like CC
and some others, like, reach out to
me, you know, just supporting.
- You know, I give a lot of credit to, you know, the
club, you know, for doing what they
could as well, far as making efforts.
And me and Devin met on a Zoom
call, you know, speaking about being
Black in baseball, you know,
different experiences that we had
had, you know, growing up and then speaking
about it and just trying to connect,
you know, the African Americans in the
game the best way we knew
how. So, I'm appreciative of them
for setting that up as well.
You know, there's a lot of different
avenues that, you know, started to show
themselves, whether it be group chats,
whether it be meetings in the hotel.
And, you know, I think guys really started to
understand the magnitude and put that
sense of urgency on us sticking together and
having each other's back, you know? And it
really started to show itself throughout
the year in a lot of different ways.
- And, Doc, I wanna go back to you.
Because, you know, you're the generation
before me, before Ryan, before all of us.
The activism that is allowed
today versus back in the ‘80s,
what is the difference that you see,
that you lived through then and that,
although you're not in uniform, you live
through because you're a Black man today?
- If we’re talking ‘86, the guys on
our team was pretty close, but at that
time, it's just a different generation.
We had some situations where it
kind of got heated, you know, with
racial comments being made on the
bus from alcohol or what have you.
And they’d say they apologized,
but it's totally different now.
I can see the culture is now.
It is different, and
we did have more Blacks,
I think, in my generation. I
came up in ‘84 with teams and
different teams. The way it is now,
I think now it's almost
like, one to a team, I think I heard.
Totally different, but probably
more difficult, I would think, now than what
we had, because we did have at least
three or four that we could hang out
with at times on the road or
just have those conversations.
You know, just talking, you know,
nothing serious or
anything like that, but sometimes we
might just want to talk about certain things.
We had four or five guys
you could do that with, where now, you
know, these guys, they probably know
better than I do, but it don’t seem
like there’s that many on the teams.
Some teams don't even have any. You know, they
have the Latin ballplayers, but not the Black ballplayers.
- I wanna go here next with our, baseball's
version of Colin Kaepernick,
and that’s Bruce Maxwell,
who, much like you, Devin, was solo.
I mean, one brother on a team.
A clubhouse full of people that
don't really understand the impact
of what's happening
in today to Black men to
every time we leave the house,
we're looking over our shoulder.
We're in the big leagues.
We make money. We see
lights, we still get nervous.
It doesn't matter how much money we have.
It doesn't matter how
much we've accomplished.
When we take off and leave our houses,
we know all they see is the skin color.
I might be the nicest person in the world.
I might be the meanest
person in the world.
It doesn't matter.
That skin color means
something to everyone else.
So, then you have Bruce Maxwell, who
decides, “I'm gonna take a knee
during the national anthem” and
stand up for what he believes in.
And,
to be honest, no one
had his back. As rookies,
I don't expect you guys to come out and
to say anything. That's—
it's kinda hard to say that's not
your place, but it's kind of not your
place to be on the forefront of that.
But he had to do something that
he believed in. A rookie, you know,
taking the knee, close to San Francisco,
to Oakland, Bay Area, where it
happened with Colin Kaepernick.
How do you feel about the way
he was sacrificed and having an
opportunity to come back to the
A's and saying, “I don't want it”?
- I just think, you know, at that
time, guys were scared.
You know what I mean?
Scared to support that
because of the backlash.
I mean, you saw what happened with him and
you saw what happened with Kaepernick. But
we don't really hear about him that
much because he's not, he's not the
name that Kaepernick is. Like, he kind
of just got pushed to the side and
forgotten about. And, you know,
that's really sad to see, but I also
really respect the fact that he
declined the offer to come back.
- I think it did set an example for,
you know, this year being able to,
you know, understand the magnitude of
a decision like that and being able
to connect with other players, you know,
to prepare, to try to
make a unified stance.
You know, I think it definitely
helped pave the way for that.
And, so, you know, that's something that's
always valuable. You know, moving forward
is us understanding that, you know, when
one of us wants to try to make a stance,
you know, let's come together and let's
try to do it the right way, in a way that,
you know, is gonna be heard with unity
so that one player can't be, you
know, painted as an outlier or,
you know, pushed to the side.
- You know, for us, it started with
Jackie Robinson having to go
through and take all the abuse and
have the courage to not fight back.
Although he fought back in different ways,
but not to physically go on a field and
knock somebody’s teeth out,
cuz you know he wanted to do that.
Jackie wasn't a soft dude.
Let's just make that
clear. But going with the history
of baseball from that time
to Blacks just having an explosion in baseball
to dwindling down to now you see teams
with not even one Black player on it.
I've asked myself, you know,
would I have taken a knee
had I been a current player?
And honestly, I don't know.
But the reality of it is, we all
have to answer that question.
“If I do this, what will
be the consequence?”
So, to be out there without that
support, hoping that just, you know,
because you're standing up for a cause,
that everyone is gonna have your
back, that “I'm gonna to do this for us.”
And then to find out on
the other side, everybody
Is looking out for themselves.
Even if that's not true,
that's what it feels like.
You're out there on your own.
Had that not happened to Kaepernick
and then Bruce and then everything
that happened, would baseball’s activism—
activism in baseball even existed
like it is today?
- No self-pity with me, but
the thing that happened with me and
Sheff in Tampa, when
that stuff took place, and the thing that
hurt me the most, it was not that
this incident that happened.
But everybody was saying that, “Oh, you
must have done something wrong.” Cuz we're
Black, we must've done something wrong.
That part bothered me. And a lot of this stuff
took place, happening just to
bring attention to what’s going on.
And unfortunately, we had a couple
of brothers lose their lives.
You know, with Floyd and
others, to get the attention. And
then with the protesting, the
marches, and having the white people march
also, bringing attention to
what's going on.
I’d say now, just doing what you’re comfortable
with doing. I don't think we
have to do anything—I’m just speaking
really for myself. You gotta do something—
before y’all do it because you think you gotta do it,
do what you feel comfortable with
in your own skin and
understand that before you do something,
“Is this something I really want to
do?” and consequences that come behind that,
whether it's good consequences or
bad consequences and understand that.
And asking yourself,
“Am I gonna be OK
to live with this? Is my family gonna
be OK to live with this?”
Then you take the stance.
But you still want you to
feel what’s right in your heart.
Carry on the message.